THERE WERE SIX TWENTY SIR
MICHAEL ORDER PLEASE ADVISE
ON AUDIO AND VIDEO RECORDING
OF TODAY'S PROCEEDINGS BE ME
IS ALSO BEING TELEVISED EXCEPT
FOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL COOLEY
HERE CUNNINGHAM THERE CARILLO
CAN'T FLORA THERE GRAYSON
KAMLAGER-DOVE HERE MAIENSCHEIN
MATHIS YOUR PARKS OVER HERE
PROBLEMS HERE RIVAS WICKS
HERE WE HAVE A PLAN WE HAVE
A QUORUM WE ALSO HAVE CONSENT
AGENDA PLEASE NOTE THAT WE
ARE MOVING AB TWELVE ELEVEN
ALSO A BEFORE CONSERVE SIX
FROM THE LIST OF REFERRALS
THESE BILLS WILL NOT BE FOR
LATER ON THE CONSENT AGENDA
HOW DO I HAVE A MOTION YES
SECOND MOVE MY COLORED OF
SINGLE MEMBERS WORKS OF MANAGE
SEARCH FOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
COOLEY HI COOLEY AYE CUNNINGHAM
CUNNINGHAM I. CARILLO AYE
FLORA -- FLORA AYE AYE GRAYSON
BY RACE AND I CAN LONGER
HERE YES HI -- I MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN AYE MATHIS MATHIS
AYE QUIRK SILVA QUIRK SILVA I
RAMOS RAMOS I RIVAS WORKS
HI WHAT I WAS IMPRESSED
ME FOR A TURN THIS MEET I JUST
WANT TO KNOW WHAT OTHER THINGS
DONE DURING THIS BREAK WAS
ACTUALLY REQUIRING THE
TELEVISION SYSTEM PUT US ON AN
HD SYSTEM OF TO SUPPORT
THE PROP SIXTY FOUR OBLIGATION
CAN ALSO INVOLVE MOVING THE
TELEVISION OFFICE FROM THE
ANNEX INTO THE BASE FOR THE
WEST WING SO IN THAT SENSE THAT
COMPLETED PROJECT -- IS THE
FIRST TANGIBLE EFFECT OF THE
ONGOING IN ACTION MUCH IF YOU
HAD TO MOVE THAT CRITICAL PUBLIC
FACILITY OUT OF THE ANNEX
WORD WOULD IN DUE COURSE BE
DISRUPTED TO ENSURE CONTINUITY
OF OPERATIONS AS YOU MOVE
ALONG -- THAT OFFICE IS ON
THE BASE FOR THE WEST WING ON
THE NORTH QUARTER PAST TO TOUR
OFFICE RIGHT FOR YOUR HEAD IN
THE BASEMENT AND I WAS CERTAIN
ENCOURAGING OF YOU THAT HAVE
AN INTEREST TO GO IN AND JUST
CHECK OUT WHAT OF OUR STAFF
TO HER BELLY AND LABOR HAVE DONE
OVER SPEND A TIME TO REQUIRE
THE CHAMBERS THE BUILDING
PUTS ON H. T. AND OF COURSE
THAT MEANS -- SOME OF US
WILL NOT BE APPROVED BY ANY
AMOUNT OF MAKE UP TAKE NOTE
OF OF THE AUTHENTICITY OF HD
PLAN ACCORDING BUT I WELCOME
YOU TO TWENTY TWENTY IT IS YEAR
OF IN OPERATIONS
THANK YOU THE GERMAN